okay is Madison Beer from Long Island
you know it baby what you talking about
of course I'm from Long Island I grew up
in Long Island which isn't sorry if I'm
offending any long Islanders but I'm a
long Islander so I can say it it's not
as cool as Manhattan it's just not so
whenever I tell people I'm from New York
I'm just hoping they just assume
Manhattan they don't ask me but I think
the Wolf of Wall Street kind of put Long
Island on a little bit and now people
are like oh my God can you do the Marco
Robbie accent I'm like yeah I can do the
Mario Robbie accent I can give you her
whole little Spiel ready okay she says
well aren't you married
he says yeah American people can't have
friends oh we're gonna be friends we're
not going to be friends
there's my Margot Robbie off of Wall
Street impression everybody but yeah I
love being from Long Island I love the
accent I mean they should start the rest
of the video we're gonna talk like this